nous commençons ce thème de trois
rivières ce soir avec une question
d'elisabeth darveau madame darveau
bonsoir à vous ben ça alors madame d'un
volet chef vous écoute votre question
dans une ère où nous sommes de plus en
plus touchés par la cause
environnementale et où l'onu a déclaré
l'urgence climatique
il devient urgent de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour contrer
cette crise
ma question est la suivante sachant que
si nous n'agissons pas maintenant nous
atteindrons le point de non retour qui a
le premier changement concret comptez
vous faire pour protéger l'environnement
merci madame darveau première réponse
justin trudeau
merci elizabeth pour pour votre question
fait c'est une question qu'on entend à
travers le pays depuis plusieurs
semaines au sillonnent le pays pour
parler aux gens qui justement nous
disent l'avenir de leurs enfants
l'avenir de l'environnement les plats
lutte contre les changements climatiques
c'est essentiel on a beaucoup fait sur 4
ha mais on doit continuer et on doit
pouvoir tenir tête contre ces
conservateurs comme john kani tom ford
et les pétrolières qui les appuient pour
pouvoir justement à continuer de lutter
contre les changements climatiques y
bâtir un monde meilleur
c'est pour ça que le choix que vous
faites ce soir est si important mais
pourquoi aussi j'ai confiance dans les
canadiens j'ai confiance dans les
prochaines étapes qu'on va entamer
ensemble
merci monsieur trudeau monsieur bernier
bonsoir les autres partis vous disent
qu'ils vont atteindre les cibles de
l'entente de paris mais ils ne pourront
pas les atteindre puisqu'il faut imposer
une taxe sur le carbone de 300 dollars
la tonne pour ce faire et ils ne le font
pas et où s'ils le disent qu'ils vont
sauver le monde sauver le climat
mais comme vous savez les émissions
globales du canada représente seulement
2,6 pour cent des émissions totales
nous au parti populaire on veut se
concentrer sur des gestes concrets pour
l'environnement s'assurer que nos eaux
soit dépollué notre sol notre ère et je
pense qu'on peut réinvestir pour
protéger réellement l'environnement et
pas être hypocrite comme les leaders ici
autour de moi qui disent tout faire pour
aider les changements climatiques mais
dans le fond ils n'ont pas de solution
monsieur singh
merci elizabeth c'est vraiment gros
enjeu je sais qu'au québec on a eu des
inondations sévère on a eu des feux de
forêt c'est vraiment un impact réel
qu'on fait face à ce moment on a eu des
milliers d enfants dans les roues dont
ce qu'on propose deux maintenant pas
comme si le trou d'eau qui a acheté un
pipeline
on veut annuler tout de suite tu des
subventions pétrolia s'assure une étape
on peut prendre tout de suite et on va
réinvestir l'argent dans l'énergie
renouvelable dans l'énergie propre
aussi on veut réinvestir massivement
dans le transport en commun
on peut agir c'est cette question que
d'avoir le courage on a le courage merci
monsieur singh monsieur oui
l'environnement c'est un des enjeux
central de cette campagne et comme père
de cinq enfants
je veux assurer que nous lasse les
prochaines générations une environnement
plus propre que nous avons hérité a mais
malgré ce qu'ils prétendent justin
trudeau ressources est un dossier
son plan est un échec une des premières
décisions qu'il a prises comme des
premiers ministres d'autoriser de
déversement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eaux usées dans notre fleuve
mon plan à mettre fin au déversement
d'eaux usées parce que nous sommes en
merci monsieur cher monsieur blanchet
mais bien le bonsoir merci de nous
recevoir chez vous encore ce soir
il ya certainement beaucoup de mesures
qui doivent être prises je vous en
mentionnerait quelques-unes je pense que
le parlement devrait par le biais d'une
loi un peu comme le suggère monsieur
singh sur l'intention faire en sorte que
on cesse immédiatement toute espèce de
subventions aux industries pétrolières
c'est autour de 10 milliards par année
au total selon une étude d'équiterre
2018 ça vous dire quelque chose monsieur
trudeau et un autre loi pourrait faire
en sorte de contrainte de contraindre le
canada a respecté ses cibles parce que
pour l'instant les sites de 2009 de
monsieur scheer sont devenus les cibles
de monsieur trudeau et rien n'a été fait
pour les atteindre
il ya des mesures incitatives en termes
d'électrification des transports peuvent
être faites en laissant d'ailleurs si le
succès tout en vous aviez madame mais en
terminant
merci c'est vrai et
sacrément ce que vous avez dit nous
sommes maintenant trop proche à un point
de non retour
on doit éviter le pire manon c'est
seulement les verts qui a un programme
qui a aligné avec les scientifiques du
giec mais on doit travailler ensemble
pour nous renverser et sentiers de
mettre sur pied ageha cabinet de guerre
comme dans le deuxième guerre mondiale
de faire les choses ensemble parce qu'on
doit éliminer les dépendances
mj facile et en même temps être changé
notre économie vers une carrière
merci madame mais madame d'art vous
trois rivières j'espère que vous êtes
éclairé en tout cas c'est les réponses
qu'ils vous ont donnés merci beaucoup de
votre participation s'est appréciée